yeah hi Ben my name is parag khanna from
the new america foundation of a young
global leader of the World Economic
Forum you asked a very interesting
question about corruption and how
corruption can be tackled by business
leaders so that developing countries
become leaders of organization and
there's a couple of things that actually
they can do first of all business
leaders candidates that are succumbing
to corruption can expose what others are
doing in terms of being corrupt in that
way that creates a level playing field
rather than a race to the bottom where
companies trying to outspend each other
okay to be corrupt instead they wind up
clearing basically creating transparency
around who is being corrupt and then
eventually potentially no one will this
is very good for developing or trees
because then it eliminates the skewed
income or ball flora or capital or
corrupt financing that goes into
government pockets and instead focuses
much more on what how the actual
revenues natural resources for example
are being used how they're being spent
and in that actually comes play a very
important role as well and so investor
with romance then the developing
countries themselves focusing on
managing what they do get very well
rather than only having the ruffed
revenue so and when they when they do
that in fact you will find that the
country's the developing economies
actually put much more of the limited
revenues they get from actual projects
into infrastructure into welfare and
other kinds of things so that is one way
in which business leaders can contribute
to diminishing rather than creating more
corruption thank you